euh
très bien alors que nous attendons juste la
fin de cette fermeture du cône de nez,
nous aurons encore un peu de temps nous
aurons environ 20 minutes
ou un peu plus de 21 à partir de maintenant
jusqu'à ce que nous commencions vraiment à rentrer dans l'
atmosphère terrestre  nous
attendons cette interface d'entrée dans environ
21 minutes
, puis à peu près à ce moment-là, nous
rechercherons également cette panne dont nous
avons parlé,
euh, nous avons eu un peu de ce que nous
appelons une com ratée à ce stade,
donc  vous entendrez des sortes d'
interruptions sporadiques dans la transmission audio
simplement à cause de la façon dont le dragon a été orienté
pour le largage du coffre
et pour la combustion réelle de l'orbite,
mais que cette période de panne sera
due au plasma qui s'accumule autour de
la capsule
interférant  avec ces antennes
envoyant ou recevant des données
, j'ai donc entendu l'appel selon lequel le
premier ensemble de crochets
pour la fermeture du cône de nez est en mouvement,
donc cela se terminera en deux ensembles, le
premier ensemble est maintenant en mouvement,
donc de très bonnes nouvelles à entendre  t
tout a l'air bien jusqu'à présent,
comme je l'ai mentionné auparavant dans l'
arrière-plan, le dragon a
euh inhibé les propulseurs draco de la cloison avant
que nous venons d'utiliser pour terminer
cette brûlure de désorbite, c'est pour s'assurer
qu'il est sûr de verrouiller ce cône de nez
fermé pour la rentrée
également le  le véhicule a lancé la
purge
nitrox le nitrox est simplement un mélange d'azote
et d'oxygène c'est ce que nous respirons
et le nitrox qui est purgé dans
le système
est refroidi permettant ainsi à l'air frais de
circuler autour de la cabine mais aussi à l'
intérieur des combinaisons de bob et doug  aidera
à les garder au frais et à l'aise
pendant la rentrée qui arrivera
dans environ 20 minutes
[Musique]
nous suivons actuellement 23 minutes et
20 secondes
jusqu'à ce que l'entrée commence
[Musique]
donc au cas où vous nous rejoindriez à
à ce stade, le cône de nez s'est
fermé, les propulseurs avant
ont été désactivés
et nous verrouillons le cône de nez
actuellement en cours avec le premier jeu de
crochets,
le premier des deux jeux que
nous avons jus  t eu la confirmation que le premier
jeu de crochets est fermé,
donc maintenant le deuxième coup, le deuxième
jeu commencera à se fermer également
[Musique]
comme nous l'avons mentionné après que ce cône de nez soit
complètement fermé, nous
aurons quelques minutes pour reprendre notre
souffle  environ 20 minutes ou un peu
moins de 20 minutes jusqu'à ce que le
dragon commence à se manœuvrer vers
l'attitude d'entrée en
pointant essentiellement le bouclier thermique dans
le sens du déplacement
car il va ouvrir la voie
à leur rentrée dans l'
atmosphère terrestre,
nous chercherons à courir  dans cette
panne de communication
à environ 36 minutes après l'heure en
s'attendant à ce que cela dure environ six
minutes
, puis nous le récupérerons peu de temps
avant de
déployer les parachutes de drogue suivis un peu
moins d'une minute plus tard par les
parachutes principaux et à ce moment-là, espérons-le
nous devrions avoir quelques vues du dragon
rentrant dans l'atmosphère terrestre et
parachutant jusqu'à une éclaboussure
dans le golfe
afin qu'ils soient au premier rang du contrôle de mission
dans le cent  Euh,
vous pouvez voir le PDG Elon Musk
et notre présidente Gwen Shotwell assis
côte à côte à ces consoles centrales
en plus de ces deux-là, la salle est
remplie d'
opérateurs dragons et de chefs de mission
qui continuent de surveiller la santé et la
télémétrie
de l'équipage et de la capsule.  en ce moment
, la fermeture du cône de nez est en cours,
le premier des deux ensembles de verrouillage du crochet
est
terminé et nous venons d'entendre un appel
indiquant que le
cône de nez spacex est sécurisé pour l'entrée
kathy, nous le voyons à bord à droite, excellente
confirmation
là-bas du contrôle de mission
ici  bob et
doug dans l'effort de dragon euh que bob et
doug ont également confirmé sur leurs
écrans
que le cône de nez s'est fermé nominalement
et qu'il est sécurisé pour l'entrée, de
sorte que le nez clone le cône de nez
ferme l'
achèvement de beaucoup de virelangues avec
ce droit
venant maintenant avec un dragon volant toujours au-dessus du
pacifique sud
il est sur le chemin du retour nous allons
progressivement commencer à voir
son altitude baisser en ce moment déjà seulement
20  À 7 miles au-dessus de la surface de la Terre, il se
trouvait à environ 260 miles alors qu'il était
encore de l'autre côté de l'océan Pacifique au
large de la
côte sud-ouest de l'Australie lorsqu'il a
allumé ses moteurs pour cette brûlure de désorbite,
donc son altitude va continuer à
baisser
une fois qu'il  atteint environ 100 kilomètres d'
altitude ou environ 62 miles,
il va commencer ce que l'on appelle l'
interface d'entrée et c'est à ce moment-là qu'il
commence vraiment à ressentir
les effets de l'atmosphère terrestre qui
connaîtra à nouveau une portance et une
traînée
car ce n'est plus dans ça  environnement proche du vide
en orbite terrestre basse
, nous entrons donc essentiellement dans la
seconde moitié
de l'entrée, le
dragon commence maintenant à injecter du nitrox
dans la cabine
et continue de le compléter dans
les combinaisons de bob et doug,
c'est de l'air frais
qui circule essentiellement à travers  la cabine
et les combinaisons
c'est ce qui leur permettra, ainsi qu'à la
cabine elle-même, de rester confortables
lors de la rentrée alors que ces
températures extérieures atteignent 3 500 degrés
fa  hrenheit à ce stade,
l'orientation du dragon est telle que le
bouclier
thermique pointe vers l'avant si vous dirigez
la capsule
vers le site d'atterrissage
si vous avez suivi
ces deux derniers jours, vous savez
que la météo a été un élément important
pour  nous l'équipe de récupération a été occupée au
cours de la semaine dernière à travailler pour déterminer
la sélection d'un site d'atterrissage afin
d'
augmenter les options pour les
départs de
la station spatiale l'équipe a identifié un total de sept
emplacements possibles d'éclaboussure
afin de répondre aux exigences de la nasa en matière de
calendrier pour la récupération de l'équipage
ces emplacements potentiels d'éclaboussures
doivent être proches d'un port
et ils doivent être proches des
installations médicales,
donc avec tout cela à l'esprit, vous ajoutez les
conditions météorologiques en constante évolution de la
Floride, mais aussi
cette tempête tropicale isaiah qui se
déplaçait
et il est facile de  voyez comment déterminer
ce site d'atterrissage
est un processus assez complexe
puisque le dragon est capable d'éclabousser
de chaque côté du  florida panhandle
nous avons en fait deux
navires de récupération identiques et entièrement équipés prêts à
soutenir l'
un dans le golfe du mexique que
nous utilisons aujourd'hui go navigator
et l'autre situé au large de la côte est
de la floride capable de desservir les sites de débarquement
dans l'atlantique  océan que l'on
est chercheur comme je l'ai mentionné aujourd'hui, nous
allons éclabousser
dans le golfe du mexique juste au large de la côte
de pensacola en floride
aller navigateur ce navire de récupération que je viens de
mentionner est en place
et prêt et attend bob et doug
le
wb-  57 avion s'il n'a pas déjà décollé,
je suis sûr que
ce sera très bientôt dans les airs, d'
accord,
c'est ce qui fournira nos premières vues
du dragon lors de la rentrée, nous obtiendrons une
caméra thermique
de cet avion permettant  nous pour voir
la capsule alors qu'elle rentre dans l'
atmosphère
si vous étiez à l'écoute de notre
diffusion de démo un euh
là c'était essentiellement une grosse boule de
lumière qui
venait vers nous nous aurons également des caméras
à bord du navire de récupération afin que
drago  n
se rapproche de nous et déploie ces
parachutes,
nous pourrons également avoir, espérons-le,
des images très claires de tout
cela, donc l'altitude du dragon
continue de baisser en
ce moment à environ 174 miles au-dessus de la planète
Terre,
nous avons moins de 11 ans et un  une demi-minute
de l'endroit où nous nous attendons à atteindre l'
interface d'entrée, c'est donc là que le dragon
commencera vraiment à ressentir
les effets d'être dans une atmosphère plus dense
, puis nous suivons toujours cette
panne de courant à peu près au même
moment,
nous sommes à moins de 27 minutes de l'
éclaboussure
donc  nous sommes à moins de 27 minutes de bob
et doug étant sur la planète terre pour la
première fois depuis le 30 mai
pour tout mettre en perspective
vous savez la capsule dragon a
décollé de la station spatiale internationale il y
a
plusieurs heures mais d'après ce que
dan vient de dire
c'est  essentiellement à mi-chemin de la maison
juste en fonction de l'altitude seule, donc la
station spatiale internationale
est à environ 250 miles au-dessus de la surface de la terre,
je pense qu'en ce moment je  c'est entre 250 et
300, je pense qu'en ce moment, c'est à environ 263
miles
au-dessus de la surface de la terre, donc sur la base de cette
télémétrie que dan vient de lire est
d'un point de vue d'altitude, le dragon est à
mi-chemin
et pourtant cette seconde moitié va être
couverte dans les 27 prochains
ish  minutes euh pendant que nous attendons l'
éclaboussure et la récupération
par rapport aux plusieurs heures que nous avons
couvertes depuis hier
ouais ouais nous continuerons à voir
sa vitesse chuter alors qu'il sort de l'
orbite il
commence à toucher l'atmosphère il
commence à ralentir à cause des effets  de
ce frottement
générant de la chaleur sur le bouclier thermique
et accumulant le plasma éventuellement
autour du vaisseau spatial,
sa vitesse va continuer à baisser,
il est déjà inférieur à 17 000 milles à l'heure
et il tombera essentiellement à une
vitesse terminale d'environ 350 milles par an  heure
juste au moment où ces tirs de drogue se déploient et
ceux-ci vont
apparaître lorsque les capteurs du vaisseau spatial dragon, à la
fois le GPS et les capteurs de pression, indiquent au
vaisseau spatial qu'il est
au  la bonne altitude, puis ceux-
ci déploieront automatiquement ces groupes
sortant
de la partie supérieure du vaisseau spatial
utilisent essentiellement deux mortiers
ou pièces pyrotechniques pour déployer
ceux-ci pour effectuer le ralentissement et la stabilisation initiaux
de la capsule du dragon, puis après
cela, les parachutes principaux sortiront
et ralentissez davantage à environ 119
miles par heure
, puis cela continuera à
ralentir et au moment où la
capsule éclaboussera dans le golfe du Mexique,
elle ne fera que
15 16 miles par heure, une
réduction significative de la vitesse là-bas juste
le  au cours de quelques minutes,
bien sûr, vous connaissez une
vitesse assez confortable
euh la façon dont les astronautes l'ont
décrite
précédemment avec d'autres types de
missions
atterrissant également euh faisant des atterrissages terrestres
à peu près au même rythme qu'ils ont dit
que vous vous sentiez '  re in aa minor
fender bender ouais vous rencontrez
certainement quelque chose que vous ressentirez
mais ils font beaucoup de travail
avec les sièges et  les contraintes avec
ces membres d'équipage juste pour s'assurer
que même s'il s'agit d'un garde-boue, vous
avez plus qu'une ceinture de sécurité
qui vous retient essentiellement, ils sont donc
très en sécurité dans leurs combinaisons et
dans leurs sièges et ils vont  pour
rester là
-bas même après l'atterrissage du dragon, nous
aurons toujours une communication avec le dragon
une fois qu'ils seront dans l'eau, il restera
allumé,
probablement le plus important, leur
climatiseur continuera de fonctionner
pendant qu'ils sont dans la capsule dans le maintenant
golfe du Mexique et
des températures beaucoup plus chaudes que celles qu'ils ont
vues
au cours des deux derniers mois et nous
pourrons toujours leur parler d'ici
à Hawthorne
et les équipes de récupération
pourront également ouais
une des choses que nous pourrions  les voir faire en
fonction de l'état de la
mer et de tout après avoir
atterri sur l'équipage eux-mêmes,
ils auront encore quelques
tâches de démonstration potentiellement à
effectuer,
ils ont un téléphone satellite à l'intérieur de
la capsule
qui a son propre satellite un  tenna
intégré à dragon
et ils sont capables de l'utiliser indépendamment
du système de communication de dragon, donc
une chose que nous pourrions les entendre faire est de faire un
appel test là-dessus aux équipes ici
à hawthorne, nous ne pourrions pas entendre
l'appel mais vous  entendrait
le go to do it over the dragon to
ground audio que nous avons
écouté tout ce temps,
il nous reste donc encore quelques étapes de démonstration
essentiellement car encore une fois, il s'agit d'un
vol d'essai, c'est le vol pour vraiment
prouver les systèmes de dragon  pour amener les
membres d'équipage du
centre spatial kennedy à la
station spatiale et les ramener en toute sécurité sur terre
et jusqu'à présent, nous avons eu une descente sans faille,
nous avons terminé le dragon de désorbitation brûle
continue de
descendre, il est en ce moment à environ 132 miles
au-dessus du  océan pacifique très bientôt, nous
allons voir sa piste au sol traverser
l'amérique centrale au-dessus du golfe, je
veux dire dans cette éclaboussure
dans le golfe juste au large de la côte de
pensacola
dragon spacex pour l'entrée bref
ok ok d  oug nous n'avons pas de
mise à jour du timing car la brûlure s'est
bien déroulée et votre véhicule a toujours l'air
vraiment bien pour l'entrée pas de problèmes de santé
pour le moment
ok copie dragon merci
en plus l'équipe de récupération est partie et
le temps est toujours
bon les vents sont environ deux  nœuds et
vagues à environ
un pied du navire, ils rapportent
très calme à quel point le
beau temps est beau sur la zone d'atterrissage
merci d'
accord et euh la dernière pièce est que nous nous
attendons à un peu plus de com prêt pendant la
préparation d'entrée deux en raison de l'attitude du véhicule
euh donc  si vous pouvez nous obtenir votre vérification d'entrée
euh rapportez
un peu avant la préparation d'entrée deux
nous l'apprécierions
confirmant simplement avec eux que la
gravure en orbite
était excellente et que le chronométrage sur leurs
pads n'a pas besoin d'être mis à jour,
nous sommes en mesure de télécharger de nouveaux
calculs de trajectoire, y compris les temps
qui restent en direct selon ce que vous savez
comment se déroule la brûlure
et à ce stade, ceux-ci n'ont pas
besoin d'être mis à jour, il est important
qu'ils restent précis car bob et doug
leur mission principale en
ce moment est de continuer à
surveiller
l'état du véhicule et la télémétrie et les
données présentées à  eux
sur leur toucher sur leurs écrans tactiles
devant eux
et donc pendant les événements les plus dynamiques,
ils veulent certainement être conscients quand des
choses comme le déploiement du parachute se produiront
et quand l'éclaboussure est attendue afin de
s'assurer que la chronologie des événements
le séquençage
est  la précision est certainement
importante pour qu'ils restent au
courant et mis à jour des événements à venir,
juste un autre dragon de vérification rapide de la position
est
toujours au-dessus du Pacifique central jusqu'à
environ 108 milles
d'altitude et nous nous attendons à ce que l'
interface d'entrée apparaisse dans les quatre prochaines
minutes  ou alors
encore une fois, à ce moment-là, le dragon devrait être à
une altitude d'environ 62 milles terrestres
ou environ 100 kilomètres et c'est à ce moment-
là vraiment  commence à ressentir les effets de
l'atmosphère, il commence à ressentir
la portance et la traînée
et d'autres effets atmosphériques dont il a été
exempt en volant dans le quasi-
vide
de l'orbite terrestre basse, donc continuer à baisser
en altitude
tout en recherchant une éclaboussure à temps
devrait juste être  dans environ 19 minutes
et juste un rappel, nous avons cette
période de panne d'électricité à venir, alors qu'ils
continuent de
plonger dans l'atmosphère terrestre et de descendre de
plus en plus bas, l'atmosphère devient de
plus en plus épaisse et cela va
générer de plus en plus de
chaleur éventuellement chauffer le  à l'extérieur
du dragon à 3 500 degrés Fahrenheit
et lorsqu'il atteindra ce pic de chauffage, il
formera également un plasma autour du
vaisseau
spatial, nous nous attendons donc à perdre notre calme pendant environ
six minutes. Les
préparations d'entrée de l'équipage du dragon sont
terminées.
l'appel du commandant du vaisseau spatial doug
hurley les préparatifs d'entrée
sont terminés donc ils sont à bord
ils surveillent ils sont prêts à rentrer à la
maison
ouais et comme  en ce moment, euh, la préparation d'entrée
aurait également dû inclure
une configuration finale de leurs
combinaisons de vol, nous avons donc eu une question
de nos médias sociaux plus tôt si les
visières seront
relevées ou abaissées, ces visières devraient être abaissées
à ce stade
dans le cadre de cette vérification de préparation d'entrée
dans ce dernier briefing, nous avons également entendu dire que
le temps s'annonçait beau
dans un rapport précédent, la formulation était qu'il
ressemblait à du
verre et c'est certainement idéal pour une
éclaboussure d'eau
euh cela étant dit le calendrier de récupération
euh
vous savez que bob et doug devraient être hors de
la capsule moins d'une
heure après avoir éclaboussé si bon d'
entendre
que le temps est beau, nous avons vu un
ciel bleu et quelques
nuages blancs duveteux là-bas dans le golfe
du mexique alors que nous avions des vues de notre
navire de récupération aller navigateur mais
eureux d'entendre ça  les conditions se
maintiennent
et que les vents semblent également très
bons
autour de deux et deux milles et demi
par heure, donc
presque rien du tout ne pouvait vraiment pas
demander de meilleures conditions pour un
splas  En fin de journée,
nous avons en quelque sorte enfilé l'aiguille une fois de
plus presque comme nous l'avons fait lors du lancement avec
la météo d'aujourd'hui,
vos limites supérieures de vent étaient d'
environ 10 milles à l'heure,
nous sommes donc bien en dessous de ce seuil
pour une éclaboussure aujourd'hui
le  dragon arrivant à 82 miles d'
altitude continuant à plonger
ou s'attendant à ce que cette interface d'entrée
démarre assez bientôt
où le véhicule lui-même va vraiment
commencer à chauffer,
il va continuer à utiliser ses
propulseurs draco pour maintenir son attitude alors qu'il
continue à travers la terre  atmosphère
et nous aurons cette panne d'électricité calme
dans quelques minutes et nous
venons d'entendre que la purge de la cabine a
recommencé c'est quand ils vont
rincer la cabine du dragon avec de l'
air refroidi qu'ils vont aussi faire  une
purge de combinaison
exécutant du nitrox refroidi à travers les combinaisons
pour bob et doug juste pour garder les choses
à une température confortable pour eux pendant que
la capsule passe par la rentrée
et commence à
chauffer, comme nous l'avons dit  nous prévoyons une
brève période d'interdiction pendant laquelle nous ne pourrons pas
communiquer avec la capsule,
nous nous attendons à ce qu'elle démarre dans exactement
trois minutes
qui durera six minutes au total et
pendant ce temps, nous ne pourrons pas
commander le véhicule
ou recevoir  la télémétrie étant dit que le
dragon est conçu pour être entièrement
autonome, il se conduit de toute façon,
donc bob et doug resteront attachés à
leurs sièges
et comme je l'ai dit, la perte de signal anticipée
ou comme vous l'entendrez appeler los
devrait
durer juste  six minutes
pendant cette période de panne, la
capsule rencontrera ce que l'on appelle l'
interface d'entrée, c'est à
ce moment-là que la capsule est maintenant
vraiment dans l'atmosphère terrestre et
commence à
être soumise à des forces aérodynamiques, c'est
aussi à ce moment-là
qu'une grande partie de cette friction commencera à
s'accumuler  et augmenter les températures extérieures
dragon spacex nous montrons deux minutes jusqu'à la
panne d'électricité calme prévue
nous vous verrons de l'autre côté à un
huit quatre deux
copie de dragon 1842 nous allons vous baiser alors
il y a cette communication tête haute
du contrôle de mission à l'
effort de dragon confirmant que la
panne de communication
comme je le disais pendant la panne de courant,
la capsule dragon passera par l'
interface d'entrée
où elle rencontre des
forces aérodynamiques commence vraiment à  accumulez euh
la température extérieure car elle et cette
température extérieure atteindra environ 3
500 degrés Fahrenheit,
mais l'intérieur de la
cabine est refroidi de manière écologique,
donc Bob et Doug devraient
rester à l'aise pendant leur descente,
il y aura de l'air frais qui ne circulera pas  seulement à
travers la cabine elle-même mais aussi à
travers leurs combinaisons,
les combinaisons ont des capteurs
capables de détecter
la température à l'intérieur de cette combinaison et
une fois
qu'une fois que ce capteur indique qu'il a atteint
le seuil de température maximale, il
rincera la combinaison avec certains  l'air frais
et et vraiment circuler et le
refroidir bien bien nous sommes juste autour de cet
esti  heure de panne d'électricité accouplée
lorsque nous avons entendu l'appel, nous les verrons de
l'autre côté censés retrouver
cette communication environ 42 minutes
après l'heure,
donc pour ces six prochaines minutes, ils sont
déjà à moins de 60 milles d'altitude
et c'est à ce moment-là que le  la capsule
chauffe vraiment pendant cette rentrée
atteignant des températures d'environ 3 500
degrés
Fahrenheit car encore une fois, vous frappez essentiellement
l'atmosphère à
plus de 17 000 milles à l'heure dans la
friction qui crée ce plasma autour
du vaisseau spatial,
c'est ce qui va nous empêcher  de
parler à bob et doug ou de récupérer des
données du vaisseau spatial pendant les
six prochaines minutes alors
que les ordinateurs de vol sont sous contrôle
bien qu'il continue à
maintenir
sa trajectoire et son attitude appropriées en
ayant des dispositifs de détermination d'attitude à
bord de la capsule qui ne dépendent pas des
communications avec les satellites
et ça va continuer à traîner sur
le bon chemin
pour cette éclaboussure au large de
Pensacola, donc
nous sommes là  Pendant la période d'interdiction,
nous allons continuer à
attendre jusqu'à ce que nous les ayons de l'autre
côté et à peine deux minutes
après avoir obtenu l'
acquisition du signal aos avec
dragon,
nous allons rechercher ces
parachutes et nous  devrait, espérons-le,
obtenir des vues de quelques-uns de nos
actifs sur la zone d'atterrissage,
y compris notre
avion de recherche à haute altitude wb 57 qui va
s'appuyer sur la télémétrie du dragon pour
se verrouiller
dans le ciel et nous donner une vue infrarouge
du  capsule pendant les étapes finales,
chaque entrée que
nous allons rechercher, la drogue se
déploie environ 44 minutes après l'
heure, ce seront deux tirs de drogue,
ils vont sortir lorsque le
véhicule se déplace encore à environ 350
milles à l'heure
ce sera à une altitude d'environ 18 000
pieds, ils sortiront et effectueront un
premier ralentissement
et une stabilisation du vaisseau spatial,
puis
moins d'une minute plus tard, ils se détacheront
et les quatre parachutes principaux se
déploieront.  les voir
sortir et avoir l'air plutôt fermés au
départ, puis ils feront ce qu'on
appelle une
ouverture de ris en deux
étapes différentes juste pour
minimiser les charges immédiates sur les
parachutes eux-mêmes,
ces parachutes principaux sortiront à
une altitude d'environ 6500  les pieds
avec le dragon ont déjà ralenti à 119
milles à l'heure et ils feront
le reste du ralentissement tout le
long jusqu'à ce que nous atterrissions
dans le golfe du mexique, nous devrions être à
10 minutes de l'éclaboussure,
alors en ce moment nous obtenons notre  caméras
sur l'
avion wb 57 qui se trouve dans la zone en
train de préparer ces caméras pour nous donner
notre premier aperçu
et nous devrions encore avoir environ trois
minutes un peu moins de trois
minutes
jusqu'à ce que nous prévoyions de réacquérir notre
signal
et notre connexion avec bob et doug dans
le  vaisseau spatial dragon
si vous venez de vous connecter, nous sommes dans une
période d'interdiction que
nous nous attendions à ce que cette période d'interdiction
dure un total de six minutes et
nous sommes à peu près à mi-chemin  e maintenant,
au moment où le dragon rentre dans l'
atmosphère terrestre
et en raison du plasma qui s'accumule à l'
extérieur du véhicule,
nous sommes incapables de communiquer ou d'envoyer des
commandes, mais le dragon est entièrement autonome,
il se dirige tout seul
et en ce moment bob et doug  volent à la
maison
alors
dragon spacex com check
donc nous sommes toujours à l'intérieur de cette
fenêtre de panne d'électricité prévue, il semble que nous
recevons
euh peut-être des données sporadiques commençant à
culminer c'est pourquoi vous avez entendu que les
communications vérifient avec le vaisseau spatial
dragon spacex comm check
diver  vous a haut et fort nous sommes sur le point de
copier nous vous avons cinq sur cinq aussi
doug a l'air bien et
vous pouvez vous attendre à un déploiement automatisé de la feuille d'
accord très bonne nouvelle là nous sommes
sortis de la période d'interdiction et nous
avons rétabli la connexion  avec l'
effort de dragon avec les astronautes de la nasa bob
bankin
et doug hurley à bord,
nous avons pu réacquérir cette
communication un peu plus tôt que
prévu
et maintenant nous sommes juste  t attendre, nous devrions
être à environ deux minutes et demie
de ce déploiement initial de prise de drogue
ouais deux minutes et 26 secondes
agps a convergé
vous avez peut-être entendu plus tôt que bob et
doug éprouvent actuellement 3,5
g ce n'est pas trop mal c'est à peu près ce qu'ils ont
tiré  pendant la phase d'ascension,
tout comme une douce montagne
russe, le véhicule est maintenant au-dessus du golfe du
mexique,
il s'approche de la zone d'atterrissage au
large de la côte de la floride, près de pensacola
et là, nous avons notre premier coup
là-bas, c'est la première vue depuis le
wb  -57 avion
il entre et sort un peu
cela va être une caméra infrarouge
nous montrant le dragon
rentrant
nous avons ce retour avec bob et doug
vous avez entendu
un gps converge le dragon a trois
unités gps qu'il utilise en
fait  dans le processus de déploiement du parachute
car cela
aide avec les capteurs de pression à
donner vraiment une
altitude solide aux ordinateurs de vol
quand ils sont censés se déployer,
nous attendons la drogue c
déploiements de hutte nous devrions être à un peu
moins de cinq minutes de l'éclaboussure en
passant 15 kilomètres pour la
fenêtre de la drogue
kathy nous avons raison d'environ 14 kilomètres d'
altitude 8,4 miles en continuant à descendre
là-bas sur votre écran nous avons une photo de
la capsule alors qu'elle se prépare à  déployez à
nouveau ces parachutes initiaux, les parachutes de drogue, ces parachutes aident à ralentir
encore plus le véhicule et aident à se stabiliser en
vue du
déploiement du tournage principal
à l'heure actuelle, la capsule roule à
environ 400 miles par heure en
décélérant rapidement
et en attendant que la drogue se déploie
visuellement deux médicaments  là, sur votre
écran, nous avons une confirmation visuelle de
ces deux déploiements de médicaments,
donc deux des deux groupes maintenant
sortis, ils vont
ralentir et stabiliser le
vaisseau spatial dragon
qu'ils devraient se détacher dans quelques
instants
, puis nous allons  voir quatre parachutes les
principaux parachutes déployés
dragon sous des foules
taux décent nominal
donc le taux de descente attendu  la
vitesse attendue sous les masses
nominales, nous sommes
juste à environ 150 milles à l'heure et
déjà en baisse,
vous pouvez voir les masses maintenant se détacher
et là, nous avons la confirmation du
déploiement des quatre parachutes principaux,
nous sommes visuels sur quatre tirs, nous
sommes visuels quatre  parachutes principaux déployés
quatre principaux,
donc à ce stade, les parachutes principaux se
sont déployés, ils se
gonflent comme vous pouvez le voir sur votre
écran en continuant
à ralentir le dragon de manière significative,
nous prévoyons l'éclaboussure dans un peu
moins de deux minutes et 30 secondes,
nous avons déjà ralenti le véhicule  jusqu'à
environ 16 miles à l'heure, il fait déjà moins
d'un kilomètre
d'altitude
taux de tir principal décent nominal passant
par 700 mètres,
donc à ce stade, le dragon a sauvé tous les
systèmes de propulsion sur 600 mètres
600 mètres et nous sommes à 600 mètres
au-dessus du golfe du mexique
devrait être à environ une minute 30 de l'
équipe de contrôle de mission splashdown ici à Hawthorne
a signalé les coordonnées précises d'atterrissage
à la re  équipe de couverture,
ils sont prêts à aller chercher
nos pères de l'espace,
nous venons de passer environ 300 mètres
une minute jusqu'à l'éclaboussure
200 mètres, nous avons un renfort pour l'éclaboussure,
copiez l'attelle pour l'éclaboussure,
alors là, nous avons entendu bob et doug
signaler qu'ils se préparent pour un éclaboussure,
nous  devrait être capable de voir le golfe du
mexique ici
sur la photo juste momentanément, car nous sommes
maintenant à environ
20 mètres de l'océan
, comme vous pouvez le voir sur votre
écran, nous avons une confirmation visuelle des
copies spacex splashdown et sommes d'accord, nous voyons
splashdown
et  signifie que l'effort de dragon coupé est
rentré chez lui les
astronautes de la nasa bob et doug la moitié des
équipes de spacex et de la nasa
souhaitent la bienvenue sur la planète terre et merci
d'avoir volé spacex
c'est vraiment notre honneur et notre privilège de
voler en vol
de l'équipage du dragon et de l'effort félicitations
à
tous  bien et nous sommes dans la section
de quatre décimales huit zéro zéro
merci pour ces mots doug et nous
copions que vous êtes dans euh
quatre décimales huit zéro zéro si génial
des nouvelles
tout autour de là-bas, nos pères de l'espace sont de retour
sur terre après un voyage de retour de 19 heures
depuis l'effort de dragon spatial a
joué splashdown dans le
golfe du mexique juste au large de la côte de
pensacola en floride
et sur votre écran là-bas, vous pouvez voir nos
deux bateaux rapides et ils  sont en effet en train de
courir rapidement pour saluer l'effort du dragon car
il se trouve là le premier là-bas, nous pouvons
voir une vue
à l'intérieur de la capsule bob et doug qui ont l'air
bien même si la communication était un
peu saccadée, nous avons
entendu l'effort en trois décimales dans lequel
nous nous montrons
stable un
et spacex copies pour euh
évaluation du véhicule étape trois décimal un
stable un bonne nouvelle
stable un essentiellement ils sont debout
dans l'eau stable deux
euh aussi un autre potentiel où il pourrait
être sur le côté ou même à l'envers mais le
dragon a de l'eau  système de ballast
pour le maintenir droit où il est capable de
pomper essentiellement de l'eau de mer
dans des vessies dans la section de service de
la capsule,
mais ils sont droits, nous voyons déjà le
fas  t bateaux approchant
ils ont atterri je suis arrivé juste à l'heure
à 11 h 48
pacifique 1848
utc bob et doug maintenant dans l'eau et
les opérations de récupération qu'ils ont déjà commencé
nous voyons déjà les bateaux rapides
commencer à se déplacer
nous maintenons toujours  cette bonne
communication avec bob et doug et
l'équipe ici à hawthorne
euh très bientôt nous devrions avoir
le feu vert pour qu'ils emménagent
commencent leurs reniflements d'hyper golf et commencent à se
disputer ces parachutes mais nous pouvons
voir
bob et doug à l'intérieur de la capsule  De retour sur la
planète Terre
ouais, ces bateaux rapides se déplaceront
pour faire quelques choses,
ils effectueront ce qu'on appelle un
test de renifleur qui consiste essentiellement à
s'assurer que l'air
autour du véhicule n'a pas de
vapeurs toxiques provenant des
propulseurs hypergoliques  à bord,
donc une fois que nous aurons tout dégagé à partir de là,
le plomb de récupération d'eau
donnera le feu vert pour l'approche
et c'est à ce moment-là que le premier bateau rapide
s'approchera réellement de la capsule,
espérons-le  une petite vague pour
passer et doug à travers la fenêtre
et l'un des membres de l'équipage l'un des membres de
l'équipe va en fait
grimper sur le dragon de l'équipage et commencer à
commencer à placer l'équipement de gréement
nécessaire
pour hisser le dragon hors de l'eau
toujours obtenir un  vue depuis le wb l'
avion
volant au-dessus de nous, cela nous a donné ces
superbes vues de vraiment nos premières vues
de bob et doug rentrant dans l'
atmosphère terrestre
d'en haut, vous pouvez voir les quatre
parachutes dans l'eau,
nous avons entendu dire qu'ils ont été coupés automatiquement comme
prévu  par dragon donc pour l'instant l'équipage
se tient juste à nouveau ils vont
rester dans leurs combinaisons dans leurs sièges
nous attendons toutes ces
vérifications initiales dragon spacex venez vérifier
haut et fort aussi je voulais juste
vérifier une reconfiguration rapide et calme
merci  vous
donc essentiellement ce qui vient de se passer là-bas,
c'est qu'ils ont reconfiguré en solo si vous pouvez
simplement relayer l'
état des bateaux rapides et la
récupération au
fur et à mesure que vous les obtenez, nous l'apprécierions,
vous pariez absolut  ely doug euh nous allons
donc ce qui vient de se passer là-bas vous avez entendu euh la
reconfiguration des communications qui
boucle essentiellement la communication de bob et doug
dans le lancement excusez-moi dans l'
équipe de récupération
afin que s'ils puissent entendre les commentaires de
bob et doug
directement aussi maintenant nous avons parlé  un
peu sur l'
effort de spacex, vous pouvez faire savoir à ben et james que
nous nous en sortons plutôt bien jusqu'à présent, d'
accord, nous ferons savoir aux docs de vol que
vous vous sentez bien jusqu'à présent, merci pour
cette mise à jour.
ils se sentent bien et ils peuvent faire
savoir aux chirurgiens de l'air que tout va
bien
dans l'effort du dragon
et il semble que nous ayons
euh l'
un de nos gens qui est sur place
là-bas avec les forces de récupération le doyen du brandy de la nasa
elle a été elle rejoint euh  nous par
téléphone satellite brandi si vous pouvez m'entendre
je veux dire à quoi ça ressemble juste là sur
l'eau à quoi ça ressemblait de regarder
[Musique] les
regarder éclabousser pour l'objectif du test euh
alors restez à la console comme  nous le mettons en
place et
exploitons des copies spacex correctes nous serons prêts pour
cela dans quelques minutes seulement nous devrions
avoir le
feu vert pour vous dans un instant s'il vous plaît attendez
[Musique]
je pense que vous êtes habitué au
cœur
alors
là au centre  de votre
capsule de dragon d'écran
attendant que les bateaux rapides s'approchent
et
commencent le processus de gréement et là, sur
ce côté gauche de votre écran, nous
pouvons voir que le deuxième
bateau rapide
apparaît dragon spacex nous allons pour que le
personnel de récupération s'approche
attend personnel  le personnel de côté à
côté dans un peu moins d'une minute
copies de dragon merci d'accord donc
ils commencent à bouger
car le cas vient de dire que le premier bateau
va renifler autour de la capsule
pour toute trace d'hypergals le
second va commencer  En arrondissant les
parachutes,
nous obtenons des vues vraiment cool
du wv57 qui vole toujours au-
dessus de votre tête en
regardant vers le bas, vous pouvez voir les parachutes
dans l'eau et le deuxième bateau commence
à les rassembler,
nous essaierons une fois de plus  très vite
nous avons le brandy dean de la nasa avec les
forces de récupération randy si vous pouvez m'entendre
comment c'était de regarder ce dragon
descendre sous des parachutes
oh c'était incroyable j'aurais aimé que tout le monde puisse
avoir ma vue c'était une si
belle journée magnifique l'eau  est calme
vraiment le meilleur temps que nous aurions pu
demander et nous avons entendu les
bangs soniques car cela nous a fait
revenir, nous avons pu trouver tôt alors
que les parachutes se déployaient, c'était
très excitant pour tous ceux qui étaient
réunis ici
c'est  incroyable, nous avons en fait eu des
questions de la part des gens si
vous pouviez entendre le boom sonore et
nous n'étions pas sûrs, donc je suis vraiment content que
vous veniez de répondre à cela pour nous
euh je veux dire que nous avons tellement parlé de la
météo que
vous l'avez dit  ça a l'air génial ce que je veux dire comment
c'était pendant le trajet là-bas a-t-il
juste été
un ciel clair et une mer claire tout le long du trajet
je ne sais pas si vous pouvez m'entendre en ce
moment mais merci d'avoir posé des questions sur le
temps
si c'était  ciel clair t  voici
juste une sorte de cercle de nuages le long de l'hor
zon très bas mais
uh nous avons pu voir les parac
utes bien au-dessus le suivr
tout le long alors volon
bien nous n'obtenons aucune vue s
r le bateau alors quel genre  d'
activité se déroule en ce moment, nous
pouvons voir les bateaux rapides s'approcher de
la capsule
ce que tout le monde fait sur le bateau pour
tout obtenir
euh le prêt fait également son chemin pour
réussir je ne peux pas le voir
avec mon avec mon  bière je ne savais pas mais
oui mais nous nous rapprochons
euh tout le monde est en quelque sorte debout
je tiens des
positions prêtes depuis un bon moment maintenant
donc dès que
leur propre activité
va bien copier ça bien nous allons
garder  regarder d'ici
merci d'avoir appelé et merci d'
être là-bas avec tout le monde et
de nous avoir offert ces superbes vues c'est
vraiment incroyable euh merci brandi vous
espérez vous ramener bientôt au port et nous vous parlerons
à Houston
donc là sur votre écran  euh ooh la
vue de la caméra a changé
e c'est une vue qui nous vient de go
navigator le navire de récupération
les deux bateaux rapides sont là-bas en train
de
se préparer à tracer essentiellement
excusez-moi d'installer l'équipement de gréement
nécessaire pour
hisser le dragon hors de l'
eau l'autre bateau rapide est en train de
collecter  les parachutes de l'eau,
nous voulons vraiment
les ramener à bord avec nous, mais
bientôt ici, nous devrions en fait voir l'un
des membres de l'équipe
ramper sur le côté de la capsule
afin d'
installer le gréement comme je l'ai
mentionné
cette équipe particulière  le membre est très
expérimenté et hautement qualifié,
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer grimper au sommet d'une
chose de forme étrange dans l'océan, cela
pourrait être
un peu délicat, alors euh cette personne a
subi
de nombreuses heures et des heures de formation et de
certification afin
d'effectuer cela  tâche très importante
là-bas sur le côté droit de votre
écran, nous voyons le deuxième
bateau rapide s'approcher bien sûr,
ces deux bateaux
devaient attendre le  leur signal du
plomb de récupération d'eau
afin d'approcher à nouveau le dragon après l'
éclaboussure, c'était juste pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y avait pas de vapeurs toxiques dans l'
air
et maintenant qu'ils ont tout compris, nous
les voyons
commencer à travailler sur et autour  la
capsule dragon
donc même si l'appareil photo est un peu
tremblant, l'eau a l'air super
super duper lisse presque comme du verre,
ce qui est certainement idéal pour une
récupération d'eau
comme aujourd'hui ouais, je dois me rappeler
que c'est une vue du
navire de récupération principal qui était encore  à quelques
kilomètres
du splashdown spacex, nous avons des
balayages hypergirl et des
contrôles d'ordonnances non tirés euh la rigueur nominale est à
bord du véhicule
environ deux cinq minutes jusqu'à ce que la capsule se
lève bien la confirmation là que tous
ces
tests de vapeur hypergoliques se sont
révélés positifs plutôt négatifs qui est un
chose positive,
donc l'équipe a pu s'approcher et maintenant
le membre d'équipage
qui installe le gréement est au-dessus
de la capsule, il est difficile de le
voir  ici
parce que le navire le plus lent que le
navire de récupération principal
est un peu plus loin, mais comme nous l'avons entendu,
il ne reste que deux minutes et demie
jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient hissés hors de l'eau,
je suis désolé 25 minutes pas 2,5 j'ai mal entendu
ça oui
ils  sont rapides mais ils ne sont pas si rapides
euh nous avons aussi
entendu dire que euh le
bateau secondaire dont sa mission principale dans ce
cas est de sécuriser ces parachutes,
ils ont déjà des bouées attachées aux
deux groupes et à
deux des quatre principaux et déjà  avait les
yeux sur les deux autres, donc ils avancent
assez rapidement dans ce travail,
encore une fois leur principale responsabilité
de rassembler ces parachutes
les drogues se détachent du
vaisseau spatial
juste avant le déploiement du secteur
le secteur se détache automatiquement
immédiatement lorsque le dragon a détecté une
éclaboussure
tout cela se passe  juste par la
chronologie,
nous avons parlé un peu des
boutons câblés
que bob et doug ont sur leurs sièges
et dans leurs
écrans de contrôle et coupe  ing les pousses principales
est l'un de ces boutons
dans le cas où ils n'étaient pas
automatiquement coupés après l'éclaboussure bob
et doug auraient eu
la capacité de le faire euh si les vents
étaient plus forts et qu'ils attrapaient les
parachutes, cela pourrait certainement créer une
condition  où la capsule
pourrait être déplacée involontairement par ces
parachutes traînants,
alors je veux absolument éviter cela, c'est donc
l'un
des rares boutons qui sont câblés dans
la cabine pour
l'équipage
et encore une fois en ce moment, nous attendons
environ 20 minutes
pour la récupération principale  navire le
navigateur de chèvre pour atteindre le dragon
à ce moment-là, tout le gréement
sera apposé, puis ils pourront utiliser
l'
ascenseur hydraulique à cadre en a à l'
arrière du navire
pour commencer à tirer le dragon hors de  le
bob de l'eau et le chien ont signalé qu'ils
voyaient
les gars grimper devant leur
fenêtre sur la capsule en
train de fixer ce gréement qui fait toujours du
bien
d'après tous leurs rapports et nous
allons juste  voyez le navire continuer à se
rapprocher, il est encore à un peu plus de
1,3 milles marins, mais vous
pouvez voir les choses commencer à s'éclaircir à
notre avis car il se rapproche d'
une chose que je n'ai pas pu mentionner car les événements de la
séquence se produisaient
tout était  aller si vite juste
avant le
déploiement de la drogue, les sièges ont automatiquement
tourné à environ 26 degrés
et donc si vous repensez au moment où nous avons vu
bob et doug
alors qu'ils étaient encore en orbite et
pendant
la brûlure de désorbite et toutes leurs brûlures de départ,
ils étaient en fait allongés  plus près de
leur dos
à la position de 40 degrés où
ils regardaient essentiellement
le haut de la capsule du dragon comme si
leur estomac faisait face
au cône de nez supérieur à ce stade,
les sièges auraient tourné pour qu'ils
soient un peu plus de  une position verticale
qui est faite pour s'assurer que les
charges subies à l'atterrissage ne sont pas, vous le
savez,
ne les blessent pas, alors euh
à ce stade, ils ne sont pas vraiment allongés
sur le dos  s dans l'océan, ils sont
assis un peu droits, ce qui
leur permettrait
d'avoir une meilleure vue de l'
équipe travaillant à l'installation de l'
équipement de gréement,
donc à ce stade, nous sommes à environ 22
minutes jusqu'à ce que le dragon soit soulevé sur
le bob du navire de récupération
et doug sont toujours attachés à
leurs sièges un
peu comme un avion, vous savez qu'ils
disent de ne pas déboucler
votre ceinture de sécurité jusqu'à ce que le capitaine
détermine qu'il est sûr de le faire,
ils resteront dans leurs sièges
tout au long du processus de récupération
essentiellement jusqu'à ce qu'il soit temps d'obtenir  les
sortir comme je l'ai dit, nous prévoyons de soulever le
dragon sur le navire de récupération du navigateur go
dans environ 21 minutes
, puis dans 28 minutes, nous
ouvrirons cette trappe
et commencerons la sortie de l'équipage
également connue sous le nom de sortie
et nous avons entendu dire que le gréement est à peu
près complet
dès qu'ils arriveront à la
capsule, le
navire de récupération principal pourra
commencer à
le sortir de l'eau,
alors maintenant que le navigateur du navire de récupération
se met en route  g plus près de
la position de dragon dragon là-bas au large de
pensacola en floride, nous pouvons voir
la capsule un peu plus en détail
ce n'est certainement plus une
teinte blanche brillante
comme nous l'avons dit ces températures extérieures
atteignaient jusqu'à 3 500 degrés
Fahrenheit
donc les systèmes
de protection thermique
permettent au dragon de revenir tout en maintenant
la
température interne plutôt
tempérée vous voyez quelques
bateaux de plus
que prévu l'équipe travaille actuellement
euh avec quelques navires privés
dans la région en s'assurant qu'ils
sortent de là
alors
donc
et maintenant nous voyons l'un des bateaux rapides spacex se
déplacer, nous sommes donc informés que l'
équipe de récupération envoie une
radio aux navires dans l'
eau près du dragon de l'équipage pour quitter la
zone
afin que nous puissions extraire bob et
doug  en toute sécurité,
vous savez aussi pour la sécurité de ces
gens dans la région,
pas seulement bob et doug ouais c'est
c'est évidemment une opération dynamique l'
une des premières minces  gs que nous faisons
est de nous assurer qu'il n'y a pas
essentiellement de vapeurs toxiques autour de la
capsule, donc
quelque chose comme ça
peut vraiment mettre en danger le tout,
mettre en danger les membres de l'équipage et se mettre
en danger, de sorte que
l'équipe spacex se déplace pour essayer
de les éloigner
afin qu'ils puissent  récupérez en toute sécurité la capsule du dragon
et placez bob et doug
sur le pont et en toute sécurité à l'intérieur de leurs
quartiers médicaux afin que
nous puissions les voir, ils se rapprochent beaucoup,
nous attendons
environ 10 minutes jusqu'à ce qu'ils
soient en position
tout le gréement a été apposé sur  la
capsule du dragon
et une fois arrivés, ils pourront
utiliser cet ascenseur hydraulique
pour faire monter et sortir le dragon de l'eau
afin que le navigateur du navire de récupération
se rapproche de plus en plus de l'
effort du dragon
alors qu'il attend
sa récupération comme il attend d'être  hissés
hors
du golfe du mexique à nouveau nous avons atterri juste au
large de la côte de la floride
près de pensacola
peut-être que la prochaine fois nous ne devrions pas annoncer
notre zone d'atterrissage
oh là nous avons eu un coup de notre avion wb-57
on dirait que cette zone s'est
considérablement dégagée,
donc c'est bon à voir
et nous entendons également dire que tous les
parachutes ont des bouées dessus, donc aussi de
bonnes nouvelles alors
que le processus de récupération se poursuit pour la
démo spacex 2.
dragon spacex pour la configuration du camarade
allez-y  mike hey doug nous sommes sur le point de
reconfigurer le lien vers l'avant nous pouvons le
perdre pendant environ une minute ou deux
et cela devrait arriver sous peu
kathy ouais rappelons-nous
quand vous pensez que nous l'avons récupéré
nous le
ferons comme le principal  le navire se rapproche, il
va reculer
et installer son ascenseur hydraulique juste à
côté de la capsule du dragon toujours dans l'
eau
bob et doug toujours à l'intérieur en
attendant cette récupération,
nous devrions commencer les opérations de levage
dans les 10 à 15 prochaines minutes
et ensuite  ce sera un ascenseur assez rapide
hors de l'eau en utilisant cet
ascenseur hydraulique dans le nid de dragon
sur le pont du bateau ou du navire
plutôt, puis ils le déplaceront
sous l'héliport dans essentiellement
l'ar de récupération de l'équipage  ea où ils
auront une plate-forme jusqu'à la trappe,
ils pourront ouvrir la trappe
le médecin spacex sera le premier à
franchir la porte capable de faire un
enregistrement rapide avec bob et doug sur leur
statut, puis
lui et les autres médecins,
chirurgiens de l'air
et techniciens formés, commenceront à les
aider à sortir de la capsule
ouais plus tôt juste après l'éclaboussure, nous
avons entendu bob et doug rapporter qu'ils
se sentaient bien
après leur rentrée, donc cela a été transmis au
chirurgien de l'air
et  bonne nouvelle ici
encore, c'est une vue venant de l'
avion wb 57 alors qu'il fait le tour de la zone et nous pouvons
voir un
dragon attendant d'être à nouveau
sorti de l'
eau, nous prévoyons que l'
ascenseur commencera dans un peu moins de 15 minutes, nous sommes
approchant
14 minutes ici, puis
dans 21 minutes, nous aurons
une écoutille ouverte, vous pouvez voir le
navire de récupération principal en haut à droite,
c'est l'héliport
avec le grand spacex en haut, il recule maintenant
vers la capsule
certainement pas pour  être confondu avec l'un de
nos
drones d'atterrissage,
il y a une vue en direct du dragon
du dragon flottant dans l'eau là-bas
en arrière-plan avec de
nombreux spectateurs certainement à une distance plus sûre
à ce stade,
il s'agit d'une prise de vue en direct provenant de go
navigator
notre principal navire de récupération  ici donc son
crew dragon est également accompagné
des bateaux rapides qui aident à le rapprocher
et là vous pouvez voir quelques membres de l'
équipe de récupération sur le pont
et aussi juste derrière eux nous avons notre
première bonne vue
du nid euh  oui donc c'est euh
essentiellement le nid en arrière-plan
, le dragon sera hissé à l'aide de l'
ascenseur hydraulique
hors de l'eau et dans ce nid, ce
nid sera ensuite tiré
vers la caméra depuis cette vue
vers ces individus sur ce
pont supérieur là
-bas et c'est  où le spacex com
fort vérifie clairement en solo comment nous fort et
clair aussi et d'après la
vidéo on dirait que le bateau est à environ une
longueur d'environ cinq à dix mètres en
arrière  à vous de
copier ça euh merci pour la mise à jour d'
accord, alors bonne nouvelle là-bas, nous
nous préparons à voir le dragon être
sorti de l'eau
et dans le nid de récupération car je
disais que le nid sera tiré vers
la caméra
vers le  pont supérieur que nous avons vu là
-bas et c'est là que les brancards médicaux
attendront
pour les aider dans les baies médicales pour
évaluation après la sortie de la capsule,
cela fait déjà 25
minutes qu'ils ont éclaboussé, cela ne semble pas
être définitivement le plus rapide  25
minutes de la journée,
le calendrier que nous prévoyions
était que les opérations de levage commencent
dans environ 30 minutes, nous sommes donc à peu
près sur le calendrier, mais
cela a été une chose assez courante
jusqu'à présent aujourd'hui, vous pouvez les voir avec l'un
des  les bateaux rapides le positionnent
pour commencer
à sortir avec le gréement supplémentaire
à fixer à la capsule du dragon où
ils vont utiliser ce cadre en A
pour le sortir de l'eau et vous
pouvez voir  e le nid de dragon tout en
bas, c'est
cet objet circulaire avec le a1 juste
dessus,
alors que c'est la première fois que nous
récupérons une capsule avec des membres d'équipage
à bord,
l'équipe de récupération a traîné juste
pour vous faire savoir que nous avons quelques lignes
connecté et
euh le gréement est en cours de
suppression de cet ensemble de jeu là-bas, alors
informez simplement
l'équipage qu'ils pourraient ressentir un euh
élan alors
que les lignes comme quelques
lignes de gréement sont attachées
euh là, nous pouvons en fait il y a notre
premier bon coup de l'individu
qui place à nouveau cet équipement de gréement,
c'est quelqu'un qui est
hautement spécialisé et
très bien formé pour ces opérations,
car je disais que l'équipe de récupération a
répété et pratiqué cela
avec bob et doug eux-mêmes en fait dans
une
capsule de test pratiquant la
sortie ainsi
qu'eux  ont récupéré excusez-moi, ils ont
pratiqué le processus de récupération à
plusieurs reprises et en fait, grâce à ces
entraînements,
ils ont réussi  y a réduit
de moitié la période de récupération par
rapport à la première mission de démonstration,
il est donc très agréable de voir que le
processus lui-même,
après avoir été répété et soigneusement
chorégraphié,
se déroule à nouveau très efficacement, la
sécurité est la priorité numéro un,
alors assurez-vous que
seul le personnel impliqué dans
des opérations de récupération actives sont présentes sur le
pont,
vous nous avez peut-être déjà entendus mentionner
qu'il y a environ 40 personnes
à bord aujourd'hui, mais nous ne voulons certainement pas
que quiconque soit en danger
ou tombe par-dessus bord,
ce type a intentionnellement sauté en parlant
de tomber par-dessus bord,
nous sommes prêts  merci d'accord, donc l'
équipage vient d'être informé
dans environ 30 dans les 30 prochaines secondes qu'ils
ont les lignes apposées, donc ils
vont commencer à soulever la
capsule hors de l'eau et à ce stade,
la communication que nous obtenons avec
dragon
est en fait acheminé à travers le
bateau lui-même à ce stade
afin que nous puissions voir l'ascenseur,
le dragon est hors de l'eau ouais alors
maintenant un cadre va commencer à se
balancer  remettez-le en arrière et il se
dirige directement vers ce nid en bas
de votre écran
afin que nous obtenions une meilleure photo de
tous les points dans lesquels le dragon est
attaché
à l'ascenseur hydraulique en s'assurant qu'il ne
se balance pas librement
là-bas, nous pouvons voir  effort de dragon étant
soigneusement déposé
dans le nid de récupération au-dessus du navigateur go
dragon spacex bienvenue à bord du
navire de
récupération le personnel de récupération effectue les dernières
vérifications et se prépare à vous traduire sur
la plate-forme de sortie
soyez heureux merci
donc pour la première fois en deux mois nasa
les astronautes bob benkin
et doug hurley sont sur une sorte de
sol je suppose que nous ne pouvons pas appeler cela un
sol solide car c'est un navire
mais euh c'est la première fois
qu'ils ne sont pas
dans l'espace euh sur une fusée ou dans
l'océan
alors maintenant  qu'ils sont dans le nid, ils
vont commencer à le traduire vers l'avant
et le dragon va se déplacer essentiellement dans
la section de suspension
sous cet héliport, puis jusqu'à
cette plate-forme de récupération que nous avons vue un
peu  un peu plus tôt
à ce moment-là, euh, les
techniciens de l'engin spatial travailleront pour
ouvrir la trappe comme nous l'avons dit précédemment, c'est
un processus manuel
avec quelques
pièces jointes différentes que vous devez engager avant que
la trappe elle-même puisse être ouverte,
ils l'ouvriront et puis
neil menon de spacex sera le premier à traverser
l'écoutille pour
vérifier bob et doug obtenir leur
évaluation de santé initiale voir s'ils sont prêts à bouger
, puis nous commencerons à les aider à sortir
de la capsule et à entrer dans cet
établissement médical sur le  bateau
à ce stade, l'équipe de récupération fait
euh la
sécurisation finale de la capsule en
vue
de déplacer le nid de récupération
euh plus près de l'intérieur du
navire, ce sera en fait
dans un peu d'un pont couvert là où
nous avions nous avons vu  cette vue de la caméra plus tôt en
regardant directement depuis le centre
du bateau, donc une fois que le
dragon est sécurisé dans le nid, le nid
sera traduit
puis vers l'avant et plus près de la récupération,
excusez-moi plus près de la position que je  n dans
lequel nous sommes en mesure d'ouvrir la
trappe,
donc pendant que le dragon est à bord en toute sécurité, nous
ne sommes pas en mesure de le
faire pour l'instant ouais, ils
travaillent pour détacher certaines de ces lignes
qui ont été utilisées pour le hisser à l'aide du
a-frame et
nous avons entendu dire qu'ils devraient en finir avec
cela dans un instant
, puis nous commencerons cette traduction
afin que nous puissions maintenant voir l'
équipe de récupération
libérer les lignes de sécurisation qui ont été
utilisées
lors du levage de la capsule de l'
eau
dans le nid afin qu'ils libèrent
ces lignes de sécurisation des côtés
en s'assurant qu'il est sécurisé par le bas
et là, nous voyons le dragon avancer,
regarder aussi lisse qu'un tesla, je
dirais que
c'est vraiment intéressant de voir ces
marques brûlantes maintenant que nous obtenons  une très
belle
photo détaillée du dragon
debout près de la trappe latérale
ouverte
ce carré arrondi au centre
de la capsule est cette trappe latérale
et de chaque côté se trouvent ces fenêtres ovales
dragon spacex se tiennent prêt pour la trappe latérale
op  ouverture
et sortie
heureux, nous sommes prêts d'accord, l'équipage a reçu l'
appel, nous allons ouvrir l'écoutille
et si vous regardez attentivement immédiatement
au-dessus de l'écoutille, vous pouvez voir la zone
où vous pouvez les voir travailler maintenant,
c'est là que ces tirs de drogue se sont
déployés depuis le  deux cercles de chaque
côté étaient où les mortiers étaient
les parachutes principaux maintenant cachés par la
plate
-forme sous la trappe latérale
afin que l'équipage soit en train de
retirer la trappe latérale,
nous pouvons voir que le navigateur est en
transit,
il revient vers  la
station aéronavale de pensacola,
cependant, bob et doug seront transportés
depuis
le navire de récupération par hélicoptère,
donc encore une fois, nous nous préparons à ouvrir la
trappe latérale
et une fois cela fait, une fois que cela sera fait, le
chirurgien de l'
air fera un premier
contrôle  voyez comment vont bob et doug
et dragon spacex nous avons un léger
retard en raison de quelques coups potentiels ndo
près de la
trappe latérale
happy mike nous nous tenons à côté
et donc ils continuent toujours à faire ce
genre de choses  renifle donc vérifier s'il y a des
vapeurs ou quoi que ce soit pour que ceux qui
n'ont pas de dioxyde d'azote no2
puissent être principalement détectés dans l'air
à cause de la combustion du
carburant, ils vont donc continuer à
inspecter autour de la capsule pour s'assurer
qu'elle est à
nouveau sûre pour l'équipage en toute sécurité  pour les
experts en récupération
avant qu'ils n'ouvrent cette trappe,
mais encore une fois en se déplaçant le long de la
chronologie, c'est
depuis qu'ils ont éclaboussé à 11 h 48 du
Pacifique
et donc encore une fois, ils suspendent les
opérations pendant un moment en
faisant un échantillonnage d'air supplémentaire
autour du système d'hélices nous  la
télémétrie est toujours alimentée par le véhicule, de sorte que
les contrôleurs de vol ici
à Hawthorne sont capables de surveiller
les pressions des réservoirs de propulsion des réservoirs d'hélices et de
ne voir aucun problème avec ceux-ci en ce
moment,
donc encore une fois, juste une courte pause dans les
opérations, c'est encore une fois qu'ils ne font que
renifler  la capsule
en s'assurant que nous n'avons aucune lecture
qui pourrait indiquer une fuite de carburant ou
quoi que ce soit autour du véhicule,
ils ont détecté du nitroge  n
dioxyde qui est généralement
un résidu qui provient de la combustion
du
carburant, ils continuent donc à ne faire que
quelques lectures d'air différentes,
prélever des échantillons essentiellement avant de
procéder à l'ouverture de la trappe
et à la mise à jour du dragon spacex, nous enquêtons toujours
sur cela ressemble  nous allons
mettre en place une purge de la section de service nous
travaillons sur un eta pour vous
au cas où si vous venez de nous rejoindre les
astronautes de la nasa bob benkin
et doug hurley sont revenus sains et saufs
de la station spatiale internationale
ils ont fait un
splashdown à temps  dans le golfe du mexique
juste au large de la côte
de pensacola en floride à 11h48
pacifique 18h48 heure universelle
et ils ont été sortis de l'
eau et hissés sur le
navire de récupération go navigator
et en ce moment l'équipe
termine juste ils ont fait un
vérification initiale et a constaté qu'il pourrait y avoir des
vapeurs résiduelles que nous ne voulons certainement
pas être là lorsque
nous avons bob et doug sortant de la
capsule, donc
l'équipe travaille à
purger t  la section de service en préparation
de la sortie de l'équipage
juste un petit commentaire sur euh les
écoutilles
dont nous avons parlé alors que
l'écoutille supérieure du dragon est utilisée pour se connecter à
la
station spatiale internationale c'est
celle qui est située sous le cône de nez
qui est
actuellement  caché là en haut de la
capsule
avant que ce soit la trappe latérale est
ce qui est utilisé pour l'
entrée et la sortie à la fois sur la
rampe de lancement ainsi que pour venir ici
sur le navire de récupération lorsque l'
international ou excusez-moi lorsque
la capsule est  amarrés à la
station spatiale internationale,
ils utiliseront la trappe avant pour sortir
et entrer dans
la capsule
quelque chose à noter qu'une fois cette
trappe latérale ouverte,
ce sera la première fois que bob et
doug
prendront une bouffée d'air frais
la première fois qu'ils  'ai pu le
faire en deux mois
depuis qu'ils sont montés à bord du falcon 9 au
début de leur
mission le 30 mai
ouais avec une éclaboussure à temps ils
reviennent avec almos  t exactement
64 jours dans l'espace sur cette mission à
quelques minutes de cela,
donc je sais qu'ils l'attendent avec impatience
dans un état un peu plus
stable maintenant qu'ils sont sur le bateau
pas dans l'eau euh mais encore une fois  notre équipe
continue juste d'avancer,
ils signalent qu'ils
voient euh tous les niveaux de vapeur
qu'ils ont initialement détectés ont
baissé euh dans cette section de service spacex
nous avons montré que les niveaux diminuent
mais continuent avec la purge
et  en plus juste pour que vous sachiez que nous
ne voyons aucune
indication de fuite ou quelque chose comme ça
ce sont des niveaux assez petits mais
nous devons encore faire la purge en ce
moment d'
accord cappy ouais vous lisez notre esprit
mike nous nous demandons juste  si vous avez vu des
indications d'une fuite ou d'une
dépressurisation quelque part, mais il semble
que cela
fasse partie de l'accord,
ouais, c'est une bonne lecture,
alors nous continuons simplement à avoir
une vue juste à la trappe de la
capsule, ils
sont d  En détectant ces très petites traces
d'un couple d'hypergals, celui que
nous avons entendu spécifiquement mentionné était
ndo ou pas trois azote ou no2 dioxyde d'azote,
ils sont à des niveaux très bas évidemment
pas
à un niveau très nocif car nous avons encore des
gens à proximité  à la capsule
qu'ils traversent avec la purge,
ils ne voient aucune indication
de fuite dans la section de service du
dragon, c'est là que se trouvent à
peu près tous ces différents
réservoirs de carburant avec les hyper
galles à l'intérieur de la capsule
et nous sommes à peu près  44 minutes après l'
éclaboussure en
fait toujours en avance sur la chronologie, car
nous ne nous attendions pas à
ouvrir la trappe avant 60 minutes,
moment auquel nous apporterions bob et
doug, donc
cette section de service spacex une autre
mise à jour la purge de la section de service devrait
commencer dans un peu moins de cinq minutes,
euh en ce moment, nous montrons environ 2 fois
nos limites d'exposition personnelles
et nous espérons qu'une fois que nous aurons commencé la purge,
cela baissera pour nous
ok merci le mien
et je vais devoir me corriger donc
ce n'est pas le
tétra oxyde de diazote et c'est l'un des
carburants hypergoliques utilisés à l'intérieur du dragon
pour alimenter ces propulseurs draco
donc encore une fois les ingénieurs de spacex détectent des
niveaux de nto
c'est du tétra oxyde de diazote c'est  l'un
des carburants hypergoliques utilisés à l'intérieur des
niveaux de vaisseau spatial dragon plus élevés qu'ils ne le souhaiteraient,
ils font donc essentiellement une purge pour
aider à
dissiper les vapeurs dans et autour de la
section de service où ces
réservoirs de carburant résident dans la capsule dragon,
nous nous attendons à ce que  prendre dans les
cinq prochaines minutes environ,
nous nous attendions toujours à ce que l'équipage sorte
dans une heure,
donc toujours sur la chronologie ou quelques
minutes à venir
et nous devrions voir bob et doug
une fois que nous verrons ces
niveaux continuer à baisser autour de la
capsule nous '  Je vais recommencer à
parcourir le processus d'ouverture de la trappe,
donc les
chiffres,
donc en ce moment, nous nous préparons à
purger la section de surface,
c'est pour nous assurer que le l  l'ingérence dans les
fumées que
l'équipe détecte est évacuée
essentiellement la section de service
n'est pas la cabine intérieure où se trouvent bob et
doug,
c'est en fait la partie de la capsule
qui se trouve à l'
extérieur de l'endroit où se trouvent bob et
doug, c'est à l'extérieur du au  cabine
mais c'est à l'
intérieur de la capsule elle-même, vous pouvez donc la
considérer
comme l'espace entre l'extérieur
de la capsule du dragon et l'espace intérieur
où se trouvent bob et doug, je pense que
le récipient sous pression intérieur est essentiellement
oui
exactement, donc bob et duggar trouvent l'air
qui  ils respirent,
vous savez que le mélange nitrox
qu'ils ont reçu pendant
toute la durée des
opérations d'aujourd'hui, mais
ce sera essentiellement la zone sous
leur cabine complètement
isolée de la section de service ouais
cette section de service est l'endroit où
nous il y a un  beaucoup de télémétrie, c'est
là où se trouvent les réservoirs d'accessoires et nous nous
assurons simplement que ceux-ci
sont aérés afin que les fumées persistantes
soient à
nouveau balayées.  Ils avaient détecté des niveaux plus
élevés qu'ils ne voulaient voir de tétraoxyde d'azote
qui est l'un des deux carburants hypergoliques
utilisés
dans le dragon, l'autre étant la
monométhylhydrazine,
ces deux carburants essentiellement lorsqu'ils sont jetés
ensemble, même sans source d'allumage
, réagiront, c'est ce qui en fait des
carburants hypergoliques
un  solution beaucoup plus simple et plus élégante
utilisée dans de nombreux
systèmes de manœuvre en orbite dans les
engins spatiaux,
donc encore une fois, nous sommes juste là
pour que, comme vous pouvez le voir sur votre écran, il
y a un membre d'équipage qui a une
sorte de ce qui ressemble à un dragon spacex
je ne  Je n'ai pas une
grande mise à jour pour vous, juste pour vous faire
savoir que la purge de la section de service est toujours
en cours
et nous essaierons de vous sortir de là sous
peu,
donc comme je le disais, deux personnes sur
votre écran, une
avec un masque facial et  ce qui ressemble à une
bouteille de plongée là-bas
avec de l'air respirable pur il
pourrait y avoir un autre membre d'équipage avec le
même
équipement de protection individuelle ou EPI
qui viendra
sur le pont ici ce type d'equ  ipment
on y va c'est le genre d'équipement
qui est
nécessaire pour effectuer à nouveau cette purge, ce
sont les fumées qui sont toxiques et
bien sûr nous voulons garder tous les
membres d'équipage en sécurité
pendant que nous préparons la trappe latérale
pour l'ouverture afin de  laissez vos pops euh on
dirait que les limites
baissent et deviennent assez bonnes
nous continuons toujours la purge
juste pour être
plus sûr d'
accord ça sonne bien mike merci
d'accord donc nous venons d'entendre l'appel les
limites continuent de tomber
sur ça euh  cela dans ce tétraoxyde d'azote,
donc ils vont juste
continuer à surveiller ceux
qu'ils font une purge essentiellement en
rinçant l'air autour de la
section de surface
où les réservoirs pour ces carburants hypergoliques
sont dans le dragon comme Kate en parlait,
ils ne sont pas à l'intérieur  le vaisseau sous pression
la section de l'intérieur du dragon où
bob et doug et leur atmosphère existent
euh ils sont essentiellement à l'extérieur du
vaisseau sous pression mais toujours à l'intérieur de la
coque extérieure
du dragon spacec  le radeau
tant bien
que mal et nous sommes à nouveau à peu près 52 minutes
après l'éclaboussure, nous attendons juste
qu'ils obtiennent de bonnes lectures sur les
niveaux
de toutes les vapeurs d'hypergol encore
existantes autour de la capsule
, puis ils pourront revenir en arrière.
la trappe s'ouvre maintenant, nous avons entendu la
confirmation qu'ils n'ont vu aucune
indication de fuites
dans la télémétrie qu'ils reçoivent toujours
de la capsule dragon
et donc dragon spacex nous allons purger
pendant
une minute de plus
, nous y voilà devrait être une minute de plus
et ensuite, si les niveaux ont suffisamment baissé,
nous pourrons revenir au
processus d'ouverture de l'écoutille,
bob et doug recevront l'aide
des équipes de récupération tout en quittant l'
effort du dragon, c'est le même processus
pour tous les membres d'équipage de longue durée
qui reviennent.  dans un environnement riche en gravité
, pouvez-
vous savoir être un peu discordant et faire des ravages
avec notre système vestibulaire,
qui est donc responsable du maintien de l'
équilibre et du mouvement,
bien sûr, comme vous nous l'avez entendu dire
plusieurs fois
plus tôt, la sécurité est notre priorité numéro un
avec cette
opération, vous verrez donc bob et doug aidés à
sortir de la capsule
et aidés à quelques mètres seulement
des quartiers médicaux à bord du bateau
ouais si vous avez déjà regardé une longue
durée  les équipages reviennent sur un soyuz c'est un
processus assez similaire où
ils sont littéralement sortis de la
capsule et immédiatement placés dans
une chaise d'attente
où ils subissent généralement
des contrôles médicaux initiaux sur le terrain
avant d'être ensuite transportés vers un
gonflable  tente médicale gonflée,
nous n'avons pas de tente, nous avons des quartiers
et ils sont beaucoup plus proches, donc
ils n'auront
que quelques pieds pour aller de la capsule
elle-même
dans ces quartiers médicaux, puis
une fois qu'ils seront là-bas, ils  obtiendront quelques
vérifications initiales
de leurs chirurgiens de l'air qui sont sur
place sur le bateau avec eux,
ce sont les personnes qui ont
essentiellement été responsables de leur
santé et de leur bien-être
tout au long de leur voyage  sion à l'avance,
toutes leurs données avant le vol prennent
en leur offrant un soutien avant le
lancement
, puis tout le temps à bord de
la station spatiale internationale
, puis ils sont ici avec la
ligne de front avec les équipes de récupération
prêtes à accueillir  qu'ils rentrent à la maison,
donc cela fait à peu près une minute que
nous avons entendu ce dernier appel à l'équipage,
nous devrions presque en avoir terminé avec la
purge, nous allons nous tenir prêts et
j'espère que nous reprendrons ces
opérations d'ouverture des écoutilles
dans un instant
donc
euh
alors
réessayez spacex pour la mise à jour d'
accord extérieur nous voyons euh trois
parties par million nto
et six parties par milliard de mmh néant
cependant vous
demande de desto vos déclencheurs et de prendre un échantillon
à l'intérieur de la cabine
ouais quel détecteur quel nombre comme
ouais ça '  ll être euh détecteurs deux et trois
à l'emplacement quatorze
heureux d'accord merci doug d'
accord donc nous venons de recevoir l'
appel des lectures actuelles
du nto le tétra oxyde d'azote et le
monométhyl hydrazine
euh  soit en parties par million ou en
parties par milliard, mais juste par mesure
de sécurité supplémentaire
euh nous avons entendu un neil so anil menon l'
autorité médicale de spacex sur le
bateau
demandant à l'équipage de sortir
des détecteurs d'air qu'ils ont à l'intérieur avec
eux
juste  faire un échantillonnage rapide à l'intérieur de
la cabine elle-même,
donc encore une fois, nous l'avons dit avant, nous
continuerons à le dire tout au long de la sécurité
la priorité absolue avec cette opération, donc
les
équipes vont être très méthodiques et
s'assurer que tout
va bien  mettre en place un environnement sûr non seulement
pour l'équipage lui-même
mais aussi pour nos forces de récupération, mais pour l'
instant bob et chien toujours à l'
intérieur du dragon de l'équipage, nous ne sommes qu'à
58 minutes après l'atterrissage
du dragon spacex avec un statut
allez-y doug d'
accord pour euh nr2 sur le détecteur 2 il  lit
0,0
et sur le détecteur 3, il lit également
0,0 pour mmh d'
accord bonne nouvelle 0,0 pour les détecteurs deux
et trois pour no2 et mmh merci beaucoup
c'est une bonne copie
et donc doug hurley signale des zéros à
travers le boa  rd aucune trace
du nto ou du mmh
dragon spacex pour une mise à jour de statut d'
accord, donc actuellement nos limites d'exposition
sont inférieures aux limites, mais la purge
fait en fait un très bon travail, nous avons vu
npasser de trois parties par million
à 1,5 sur le  ces dernières minutes,
donc idéalement avec beaucoup de prudence, nous devrions aller de l'
avant et laisser la purge se dérouler un
peu plus longtemps, mais nous voulons voir comment vous
allez si vous êtes d'accord pour continuer euh
avec la purge contre euh
toc  ça va et vous sortez de
là rapidement
ouais on va bien sortir mike
pas de problème ici d'accord merci pour ce
doug on va continuer à travailler la purge pour
euh nous descendre
et euh et euh merci pour le merci pour
ça
ouais  gardons tout le monde en sécurité aucune
raison de se précipiter
ouais nous sommes d'accord avec le
commandant du vaisseau spatial doug hurley
signalant que l'équipage se porte toujours bien dans le
dragon,
donc ils sont bons pour continuer à traîner
l'autorité médicale là-bas sur le bateau en
recommandant euh
tant que l'équipage va bien et  toujours
bien à l'intérieur du dragon, ils continueront simplement
la purge en essayant d'obtenir
ces lectures de traces de
toutes les vapeurs d'hyper golf jusqu'à
zéro,
car encore une fois, nous nous concentrons vraiment
non seulement sur la sécurité des astronautes, mais sur
tous les
ingénieurs de récupération  et des
professionnels de la santé sur place
également, ils vont donc continuer cette purge en
dissipant simplement
la zone immédiate autour de la
section de service du
vaisseau spatial dragon, donc c'est euh vraiment une
série de
réservoirs de carburant à l'extérieur du récipient sous pression
, alors où
bob et  doug sont à l'intérieur du
vaisseau spatial dragon qu'ils ont fait
quelques lectures rapides à l'intérieur de la cabine et
avaient des zéros à tous les
niveaux, mais ils continuent simplement à laisser ces niveaux se dissiper le ramener à zéro
, puis nous reprendrons les opérations d'éclosion,
nous ne sommes qu'un  un peu
plus d'une heure maintenant une heure et deux minutes
après l'éclaboussure
ouais c'est bien d'entendre bob et doug
rapporter qu'ils vont bien traîner,
ce qui signifie qu'ils se sentent bien et
qu'ils sont beaux  à l'aise de
rester à l'intérieur pendant quelques
minutes de plus ouais ils faisaient de
leur mieux euh
avant de partir euh de jouer leur
mal de mer dans l'attente
euh tellement bon qu'il est bon d'entendre
qu'ils vont bien encore à l'intérieur de la
capsule du dragon
et du dragon spacex  nous voyons toujours de
bonnes indications de la purge, nous
cherchons à
passer environ cinq minutes supplémentaires et à la
recherche de zéro indication si à tout
moment
vous souhaitez que nous accélérions les choses, veuillez
nous faire savoir que
nous sommes bons, continuez à faire quoi  vous
faites où vous pouvez attendre les cinq
faciles d'accord, merci doug d'
accord, nous allons donc nous installer dans au
moins cinq minutes
supplémentaires pendant qu'ils continuent à disperser les restes de traces de ces carburants hyper golf autour de la section de service de dragon
avant nous
encore une fois entrez dans l'ouverture de la trappe
euh nous allons nous allons rester avec vous
restez avec ça
jusqu'à ce que bob et doug soient hors de la
capsule et dans leurs quartiers médicaux
à ce stade bob et doug sont toujours
strappe  d dans leurs sièges,
les sièges se sont éloignés de
la position où je suppose dans l'
orientation dans laquelle vous voyez la capsule
maintenant
euh pendant leur orbite
excusez-moi lors de la phase de départ
plus tôt
ce matin et hier, l'
orientation des sièges était telle
qu'essentiellement  bob et doug auraient été
allongés sur le dos
dans l'orientation où nous voyons le dragon
maintenant
actuellement les sièges se sont légèrement actionnés vers le haut de
sorte qu'ils ne sont pas complètement
droits mais ils sont inclinés un
peu agréables et confortables là-bas
mais ils sont capables de voir dans et  par
ces
fenêtres là-bas que nous voyons de chaque côté
de la trappe latérale
, puis une fois qu'ils sont en mesure de terminer le
processus de sortie, faire sortir Bob et
Doug de la capsule
une fois qu'ils sont dans la zone médicale, ils
chercheront à  commencer à amener l'hélicoptère
car une bombe et un chien vont être
ramenés à pensacola par hélicoptère
pour les amener au rivage en
quelques minutes seulement
où se trouve un avion de la nasa  va être
prêt pour ensuite les
charger et les ramener à la maison à l'
aérodrome d'ellington au centre spatial johnson
à houston
et un dragon spacex les choses vont toujours
bien, nous attendons une autre
lecture dans environ deux minutes, donc à 1956
et j'espère que  sortez vous les gars
peu de temps après ça,
ça sonne bien, merci
à la lumière de l'une des
questions sur les médias sociaux qui
nous ont été posées plus tôt, quelqu'un a demandé si
bob et doug ont
netflix disponible sur leurs affichages tête haute
là-bas dans la capsule
et ils ont été  ils ont en fait été
assez occupés tout au long de
cette mission, vous savez surveiller la
télémétrie et les données et
vérifier le timing et je dirais que
c'est à peu près le moment où ils
voudraient certainement
quelque chose à regarder parce que euh vous savez
à ce stade leur seul travail à faire
est  euh sortir de la capsule
doit être un sentiment de succès,
mais
pour ces deux-là, je veux dire prendre le
premier vol et un tout nouveau vaisseau spatial que
nous connaissions en tant que pilotes d'essai  s est quelque chose
qui était un peu leur pain et leur beurre
quand ils étaient dans l'armée
et certainement quelque chose qu'ils ont laissé
au hasard pour
une fois qu'ils sont devenus astronautes et
vraiment un vol assez parfait pour le
dragon
euh évidemment nous aurons tout le
poste
revue de vol à venir dans les prochaines
semaines alors
que nous continuons à évaluer toutes les données
que nous recevons tout au long de la mission
et toutes les données
encore enregistrées localement sur le dragon lui
-même et nous passerons les prochaines
semaines à parcourir et à évaluer la
mission
et à travailler  tout au long du
processus de certification et nous ciblons déjà
le premier vol opérationnel actuellement
prévu au plus
tôt fin septembre
et dragon spacex prévoit maintenant d'
arrêter la purge en une minute vers
1957.
merci
d'accord avec eux pour arrêter la
purge dans  environ une minute, cela signifie que
les niveaux sont descendus
à ce qu'ils recherchaient, puis
nous commencerons
à reculer dans l'ouverture de la trappe  g
processus et
ensuite pouvoir faire sortir bob et doug ou
sortir de la capsule du dragon dans laquelle ils sont
restés
un peu plus de 19 heures à ce
stade depuis qu'ils ont quitté la
station spatiale samedi, ils ont eu une période de sommeil de
huit heures  de repos
sur la capsule sur le chemin du retour, ils
sont debout depuis
un peu plus tôt ce matin ce
poids arrivant vers 4 h 40 du
Pacifique donc il y a un peu plus de huit
heures
et un dragon la purge est maintenant terminée
une autre vérification de drager
et  alors nous devrions procéder à l'
ouverture de la trappe d'
accord bonne nouvelle merci c'est une bonne nouvelle en
effet donc confirmation que
la purge est terminée et ensuite ils
vont juste faire un
test de plus pour s'assurer que toutes les
vapeurs préoccupantes
sont parties et qu'il  est sûr d'
ouvrir cette trappe latérale et de récupérer à nouveau bob
et doug
une fois que cette trappe latérale est ouverte,
notre chirurgien de l'air sera le premier à
dire bonjour
obtenir un examen médical rapide bien que
basé sur les rapports
qu'ils ont été pro bu  t que l'équipage
nous a donné en cours de route, il semble
qu'ils vont bien, ils se sentent bien
et ils sont assez à l'aise là-bas à l'
intérieur d'un dragon d'équipage
et d'un dragon spacex, nous montrons 0,4 parties par
million sur
18 parties par milliard  de mmh qui est en
dessous des limites,
nous procédons à l'ouverture de la trappe d'
accord bonne nouvelle merci mike d'accord donc
il y a le feu vert que nous attendions
en fait le feu vert que nous
attendons depuis des
mois à ce stade c'est notre première
opportunité
dire bonjour à bob et doug nos
pères de l'espace préférés
alors qu'ils sont maintenant sur le point de sortir ou de sortir
de l'effort de l'équipage du dragon à
nouveau c'est le point culminant de ce qui
a été environ un
voyage de retour de 19 heures qui a commencé hier
alors qu'ils quittaient la station spatiale internationale
donc  cette trappe sera ouverte manuellement
et une fois cela fait, le chirurgien de l'
air anil menon dira bonjour et s'assurera
qu'il va toujours bien, puis
procédera à l'aider
à sortir de la
capsule et  d nous voyons que l'écoutille est maintenant ouverte l'écoutille
est ouverte à 12 h 59 l'
écoutille du pacifique est ouverte
donc en ce moment ils vont y mettre un
équipement qui
lisse essentiellement les bords et
s'assure que c'est une
sortie confortable de  la capsule du dragon
juste un petit morceau de structure là
pour s'assurer que la trappe restera
ouverte
et que tous les bords tranchants autour de cette
trappe latérale
sont protégés
dans la combinaison bleue là-bas c'est l'un des
chirurgiens
de l'air de la nasa pour l'équipage qui est le dr stephen hart
puis éclosion  ouvert à 12 h 59
pacifique c'est
1959 temps universel de l'univers ou gmt
tant pis encore une fois l'équipe de récupération de spacex
aide maintenant les astronautes de la nasa bob
benkin
et doug hurley à sortir
du vaisseau spatial
nous avons ouvert la trappe il y a environ deux
minutes
nous nous sommes arrêtés pour  un peu de temps alors qu'ils
détectaient juste des traces de
certains des carburants d'hyper golf, nous avons donc
exécuté une série de purges
, puis une fois que celles-ci étaient redescendues dans
des limites acceptables,
nous avons  Je peux alors commencer par la
sortie,
donc nous voyons une civière sur le pont,
c'est normal, cela fait partie de la
procédure de récupération standard
et c'est simplement pour s'assurer que Bob et
Doug restent en
sécurité, comme nous l'avons dit, le réajustement à la gravité
peut être un peu difficile.
des étourdissements peuvent souvent survenir, surtout
lorsque vous êtes sur un bateau,
donc cette civière sera simplement utilisée selon une
procédure standard pour
s'assurer que les astronautes se
rendent à la tente médicale
aussi facilement et confortablement que possible
ouais comme nous avons discuté de
la réintroduction à  à la gravité de la
microgravité peut être un peu choquant, en
particulier sur notre système vestibulaire, donc
les éléments responsables de notre équilibre
et comme ils sont sur un navire en cours,
nous voulons simplement nous assurer que nous prenons
toutes les précautions possibles pour nous
assurer que leur arrivée est sûre et
exempts de toute blessure maintenant qu'ils sont à la
maison
et qu'ils s'efforcent de retirer quelques-uns des
objets
des sièges
avant de commencer à
extraire nos membres d'équipage
Ils sortiront un à la fois
comme nous l'avons vu pendant la partie ascension de
cette mission, il y a suffisamment de place à l'intérieur de
la capsule pour
qu'ils puissent faire un backflip en microgravité,
mais étant donné qu'il y a quelques
personnes là-dedans en ce moment de l'
équipe de récupération
je vous attraperai haut et fort
juste une vérification rapide et calme entre le
dragon et le solo de contrôle de mission
du plc je voulais juste vous remercier les
gars de
nous avoir ramenés à la maison en toute sécurité avant que nous euh je
débarque de l'
effort de puce je suis sûr que doug aura
quelques bons mots pour vous aussi, mais
euh
merci d'avoir fait les parties les plus difficiles
et les parties les plus importantes du
vol spatial habité nous mettant en orbite
et nous ramenant à la maison en
toute sécurité merci encore pour le bon
effort du navire
merci bob pour ceux  des mots géniaux
c'est absolument un honneur et un
plaisir de travailler avec vous de la part de
toute l'équipe de spacex c'était génial
quelques mots initiaux de l'astronaute de la nasa
bob bankin
il est dans le siège du pilote donc vous avez entendu
il se réfère à lui-même comme plt,
nous attendons toujours que les membres de l'équipage
commencent à
sortir du vaisseau spatial du dragon de l'équipage
et encore une fois, ils vont obtenir de l'
aide à quelques mètres
des quartiers médicaux
à bord du navire où  ils
vont pouvoir
sortir de leurs combinaisons qu'ils ont
portées pendant toutes les
phases dynamiques finales des
événements de séparation désorbiter brûler
rentrée éclabousser
il y a un peu plus d'une heure à 23
h 48 ou am  une fois de
plus l'équipe de récupération spacex dragon
du commandant
va pour spacex ici nous avons notre première
vue
de nous aimerions juste en quelque sorte
réitérer ce que bob a dit et ajouter
mes remerciements à tout le monde au cours des
dernières années qui a soit travaillé à
hawthorne mcgregor
ou  au centre spatial kennedy,
toute personne touchée par l'
effort devrait prendre un moment pour chérir
cette journée,
surtout compte tenu de tout ce qui
s'est passé cette année,
nous ne pourrons certainement pas vous remercier assez notre
famille  Nous ne pouvons pas vous remercier assez,
juste fiers d'être une petite partie de
tout cet effort pour amener
les gens de l'entreprise vers et depuis la
station spatiale,
ils peuvent célébrer les uns avec les autres
et
nous vous parlerons bientôt, espérons-le, en
personne,
merci beaucoup  doug et vous êtes les bienvenus
et merci beaucoup pour ces aimables
paroles
et nous vous souhaitons tous un bon voyage de retour
et de joyeuses retrouvailles avec votre famille
bientôt et nous avons hâte de vous voir
en personne ainsi que de
très belles paroles de la part de  bob
benkin
là sur votre écran nous avons vu l'
astronaute de la nasa doug hurley sortir ou
sortir de la capsule
aurait peut-être été difficile à voir sur votre
écran là-bas mais
nous avons eu un coup de pouce indiquant que les
choses se passent bien
je suis désolé excusez-moi j'ai confondu mon
positions là-bas ouais ces mots venaient
de
doug et nous avons bob qui vient de sortir en
premier ouais donc bob bank et
le pilote le commandant des opérations conjointes
pour cette mission hors de la capsule maintenant
alors il se dirige vers la
zone médicale
et  maintenant, ils vont travailler pour faire sortir doug
hurley ensuite,
je pense avoir vu un sourire sur le visage de bob,
il était un pouce levé tout le long
car ils nous ont donné des
mises à jour régulières de l'intérieur de la capsule
qu'ils ont été  se sentir vraiment bien
et donc maintenant nous attendons juste que
notre commandant de vaisseau spatial doug
hurley fasse son chemin dans l'air frais
pour la première fois
en 64 jours,
donc d'
accord, ils se préparent et
nous devrions voir le
commandant de vaisseau spatial  Doug
Hurley sort de la capsule
et on dirait que nous l'avons fait sortir,
nous l'avons assis
et là nous allons un autre coup de pouce,
nous avons des applaudissements ici
[Applaudissements]
et comme vous pouvez le voir dans le contrôle de mission  une
ovation debout pour un travail
bien fait tout autour ouais nos
membres d'équipage
bob et doug sont maintenant de retour en toute sécurité sur
terre
et ils vont maintenant être
examinés par l'équipe médicale de la nasa ils vont
directement dans les quartiers médicaux
sur  montez à bord du vaisseau qui sera leur première
escale sur la planète e  arth
, puis ils
vont monter dans un hélicoptère
, puis retourner sur la terre ferme, donc
une fois qu'ils auront terminé, l'
équipe préparera le dragon lui
-même et commencera à le
ramener à terre,
mais juste  ça a été une
incroyable mission incroyable tout a commencé il y a à
peine deux mois
le 30 mai à partir de la rampe de lancement 39a au
centre spatial kennedy en floride
nous avons eu un décollage réussi nous avons dû
esquiver un peu de temps c'était
plein de suspense éclaircir le dernier moment possible
ils  ont fait un trajet sans faille pour orbiter un
voyage de 19 heures vers la
station spatiale internationale
où ils viennent de passer 62 jours à bord
64 jours au total dans l'espace
ils étaient en expédition 363 membres d'équipage
faisant des expériences scientifiques des promenades dans l'espace
répare
tout à bord du
laboratoire en orbite leur voyage de retour  a commencé
hier lorsqu'ils ont fermé l'écoutille au
dragon
et se sont désamarrés quelques heures plus tard à 16 h 35 du
Pacifique après quatre
brûlages de départ réussis et un brûlage de phase pour s'aligner
leur orbite
bob et doug se sont reposés avant de se réveiller
pour une rentrée plus tôt ce matin,
nous avons réussi à larguer le tronc du dragon
et effectué notre dernière
manœuvre en orbite la brûlure de désorbite
à 10 h 56 du Pacifique pour envoyer le dragon sur
le chemin du
retour le vaisseau spatial avec
succès  - est entré dans l'atmosphère terrestre et a
ralenti sa descente avec
des déploiements réussis de deux
parachutes de drogue et de quatre conduites principales,
l'amerrissage final se produisant
au large de Pensacola en Floride
à 11 h 48 dans le Pacifique juste à l'heure
après cet atterrissage réussi, nous avons
vu des experts en récupération de spacex se déplacer rapidement
et préparez l'effort du dragon pour son ascension
sur le navire de récupération
en un peu moins d'une heure
après l'éclaboussure,
nous avons vu bob benkin et doug hurley
sortir du dragon et entrer sains et saufs dans les
installations médicales du navire de récupération
mot
que l'hélicoptère lui-même devrait bientôt
atterrir
, ce sera donc la prochaine étape de
leur voyage, ils vont  prendre un court
vol de
retour vers le rivage où ils vont être
transférés dans un avion de la nasa en attente
pour un autre court vol de retour vers
houston,
ils vont être réunis avec leurs
familles et cela va mettre
fin à ce vol historique c'est
c'est  vraiment été un honneur et un
privilège de partager ce voyage avec
vous tous alors que nous ouvrons cette nouvelle ère dans
le vol spatial habité,
mais je veux dire, juste au moment où nous fermons le livre sur
cette mission, nous comptons déjà
les jours
jusqu'au prochain brut  vol de dragon ouais
absolument spacex et la nasa vont maintenant
commencer le processus d'examen des données et de la
télémétrie de cette
mission de démonstration réussie
pour nous préparer à l'équipage un qui est
actuellement prévu pour être lancé au plus
tôt fin septembre l'
équipage un sera le premier
vol opérationnel de spacex
volant un plein  équipage de quatre astronautes
dont
notre premier du Japon l'un des partenaires de l'
international
sur la station spatiale la mission
durera environ six mois
il a été un  un honneur et une joie incroyables
de partager cette mission avec le public
et les équipes de spacex et de la nasa ont
travaillé si dur pour arriver ici
et rendre cette capacité de faire voler des humains
depuis l'amérique
continuer à suivre spacex et la nasa en
ligne
et sur nos mises à jour
de médias sociaux et médias sociaux  mises à jour pour les prochaines étapes
du programme de l'équipage commercial
et le compte à rebours jusqu'à l'équipage un et nous
allons continuer à partager les progrès du
voyage de retour de bob et doug à houston sur
les réseaux sociaux,
nous avons également un briefing à venir très
bientôt, il va inclure  l'
administrateur de la nasa
jim bridenstine et les responsables de la nasa
et de spacex qui arrivent juste en
bas de l'heure 13 h 30 pacifique
4 h 30 est 2030 gmt
donc nous allons dire merci une
fois de plus pour avoir
écouté bob et doug comme  ils rentrent
chez eux et nous vous reverrons la prochaine fois
lorsque nous enverrons à nouveau des
astronautes
sur des fusées américaines dans des
vaisseaux spatiaux
américains depuis le sol américain si longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
vous